[Music]
we have the latest on Blake and Gwen's
plan to have kids out there owned their
romance is definitely burning hot
south-of-the-border
drinks in hand check big smiles on their
faces
yep and Gwen's Eddie Betty white bikini
showing off her super toned abs yep
she's got that going on too
the two are getting some R&R down in
Mexico when posted this video on the
sand and the shot of her Blake's feet
cuddled up together enjoying the view
but look at who Blake was caught kissing
his buddy
live Brian wait a minute what Chris well
it turns out Lake is one of the
headliners in Luke's four-day crashed my
Playa
concert series which ends mananas mr.
Blake Shelton he loved the beach I got a
mr. Shores finally but he's gonna let us
crash his stage crashes Playa I love
Luke like a brother
well as for the super hot and loved
couple we have got a relationship update
a source tells us that the pair has
discussed a marriage but the source says
do not expect them to be walking down
the aisle anytime soon and another
source revealed quote today would still
love to start a family together but
they're also happy with the family they
have now not just like being with her
but you know when we go places it's
always fun for me
I think somebody that can make you laugh
constantly is very sexy I think I'm as
big as fans
you